لصالح من يلعب عامل الزمن في الحرب
الدائره رحاها في اوكرانيا والصيف قارب
على الانتهاء تاتي الاخبار من الجنوب
وتحديدا زبروجيا محمله بمعطيات تقدم
اوكراني نوعي ان تواصل قد يقلب معطيات
الساحه هناك وقد يكون له فعل الدومينو
باعتبار قرب المقاطعه من اخريات لا تقل
اهميه مثل خرسون وشبه جزيره القرم اختراق
بشكل حاسم لخط الدفاع الاول لروسيا بالقرب
من زبروجيا تنقل تفاصيله جارديان
البريطانيه عن الجنرال اكسندر تنافسك قائد
مجموعه القوات العمليات والاستراتيجيه في
الجنوب الاوكراني خصصت وفقه روسيا لهذا
الخط نحو 60% من وقتها ومواردها العسكريه
لتشي وتحصينه لكن كيف تم الاختراق يقول
تنافسك انه تحقق بعد اسابيع من اعمال
ازاله الالغام معربا عن توقعه تحقيق مكاسب
اسرع مع الضغط على خط الدفاع الثاني وهذا
خط اقل تحصينا خصصت له روسيا نحو 20% من
مواردها العسكريه والامر نفسه لخط الدفاع
الثالث مستبعده تمكن الاوكرانيين من تجاوز
الخط الاول مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني
اوليكسي يستوفي كان في وقت سابق قال اذا
سقطت ميليتوبول فستن هار الدفاعات الروسيه
باكملها وصولا الى خيرسون وستقف القوات
المسلحه الاوكرانيه مباشره الى الحدود مع
القرم بدت كيف في تقدمها تستفيد من كل
الامكانيات المقدمه لها الحلفاء خاصه
المعلومات الاستخباريه الخاصه برصد تموضع
القوات الروسيه وقد يكون لافتا في هذه
الظروف حديث وزير الخارجيه الاوكراني عن
تزويد فرنسا وبريطانيا اوكرانيا بالصواريخ
بعيده المدى تساعدها في الهجوم المضاد على
نحو قد يعجل بانتهاء الحرب بينما قال وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني انهم لن يستخدموا اسلحه
النيتو في اراضي روسيا المعترف بها لكنهم
سيستخدمونها في القرم استراتيجيه كيف
جنوبا تراهن بدايه على استعاده ميليتوبول
وعينها ابعد من ذلك فهي البوابه الى شبه
جزيره القرم فضلا عن انها تقع على نقطه
تقاطع طريقين سريعين مهمين مع خط سكه حديد
تستخدمه موسكو لنقل افراد ومعدات عسكريه
تحاول ايضا القوه الاوكرانيه في هجومها
المضاد الوصول الى بحر ازوف لقطع الطريق
بين القرم والجبهه الشرقيه وكسر الهيمنه
الروسيه على شواطئه وياتي هذا عقب تقدم
حققت قبل ايام على محور اوري خوف وانتهى
الى اختراق دفاعات القوات الروسيه في
الجنوب واستعاده بلده
روبوتوكس
الاختراق فيمضي الى نهايته في الثام عشر
من اغسطس الماضي قالت واشنطون بوست ان
تقييما لاجهزه الاستخبارات الامريكيه رجح
فشل الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد في الوصول
الى ميليتوبول بسبب استخدام روسيا حقول
الالغام والخنادق وقال محللون ان الطريق
الى ميليتوبول وعره للغايه واستعاده المدن
القريبه مثل توكماك تشكل صعوبه بالغه
والسؤال لا يتعلق فقط بما اذا كان
الاوكرانيين قادرين على اختراق خط او خطين
دفاعي لكن هل يمكنهم الذهب ابعد من ذلك
وان يكون لهم ما يكفي من القوات لتحقيق
الاهم وهو دفع القوات الروسيه الى القرم